we were just going on this ambitious
feeling like we're gonna do it
gets really cool back
kind of almost spun out of control
okay back to the drawing board
yeah it seems still surreal in my brain
[Music]
cuphead is a game that would not at all
feel out of place looking like this it's
a game that is unquestionably unique and
if you've seen even a short clip of it
you'll understand why the hand-drawn 2d
animation jazz soundtrack and strict
adherence to his 80 year old aesthetic
all coalesce into an authentic 1930s
experience the team behind it
studio mvhr had never made a game before
but the two brothers leading the
operation Chad and Jared moldenhauer
didn't let their lack a formal training
get in the way yep it's always been the
goal like just a long-running thought
since kids to be like what if one day we
could make a game if we could form a
company together somehow and then the
opportunity arose and we took baby steps
throughout the progression of the game
to arrive where we're at today but we
started it with the intention of just
both of us wanting to make a game just a
background of our entire lives studying
video games and film and being very
analytical about everything and that
would be our kind of self trained it is
more self taught yeah the first half of
the entire development I was full-time
construction and then coming home to her
coming I think deep down we just wanted
to make a game that we really liked we
were just hoping other people would like
it we weren't too nervous because there
was a chance that maybe people didn't
like that type of game or didn't really
love the style and we knew that going in
so we were it was more of just an let's
release this and see what happens and
yeah sit back even if people said this
is not a game I ever want to see being
created
we still believe we still believed in it
so much that we were gonna finish it so
there was no there was definitely no
anxiety or nervousness that there was
just curiosity I think it's more
curiosity it's one just of what people
would say
and it was that curiosity of what the
game could be that put them into some
tough positions when the brothers
realized that they needed to expand the
scope of the game decisions were made to
remortgage their houses and leave both
their current jobs we started out the
game like wanting it to be small and as
we got more reception we like the 2014
reception we're like okay let's make the
game slightly bigger and we hired two
more people but it wasn't really until
2015 III like the reception from that is
when we started discussing should we
kind of go all into this like what risk
within reason like at first it was just
the money that you could put aside and
go I think we complete a game at this
size we have this scope that we would
like to do but let's first like make a
game get out there and see what we can
do after but we've always wanted to make
the bigger version like we essentially
never would have if you sat us down and
said here's what the budget and here's
the money you're gonna need here's what
you're gonna have to go ask the bank why
didn't you try to do this I would have
line yeah no I think I'm just gonna pour
some more concrete and see what happens
with that we pup as much humanly
possible as we can in the city's like
when's that money coming back we need
some of that I still haven't paid my
property tax in years and I'm like I
will tie at all and my fines sorry we
had to take a chance developing a game
with no past experience taking out loans
against their own house and hoping that
people would like it sounds stressful
enough but as we all know Chad and Jared
took it one step further with Cup heads
animation creating a game that is
completely hand-drawn is no easy task
for a major studio let alone two
brothers who have never made one before
we always joked about a 1930s style
because it was just gonna be three of us
and I was going to be doing all the
animation I have zero training in it so
we said it would be so cool if we could
do the animation like this but let's
stay away from it because yeah we could
never pull it off and that's why we went
down this other route of like testing
all these it was actual simpler
see oh absolutely like one concept was
that you would go through all of the art
up in elementary school so each world
would be crafts or art so like
kindergarten would have more things like
a Thanksgiving turkey that is like a
painted handprint with like cotton balls
and things attached and then we would do
mixes of like animating some things and
stop framing animation for others yeah I
really liked the concept but definitely
the 30s style spoke to us more and we
were like if we're gonna put in all the
work we may as well go with something
we're more interested in at this point
or happen for a long time than a more
experimental elementary school of
progression and when we came back around
and showed our friends and peers they
just it was like a a shoo-in to use that
style so we don't fin to understand the
mold inheres love for the 1930s you have
to go back nearly 80 years to when
animators like the Fleischer brothers
and uh by works were doing anything and
everything to make each of their
cartoons more wild and creative than the
last two one characters had rubber hoses
four limbs and little regard for the
laws of physics these were the cartoons
that lay the groundwork for the
animation industry and for Chad and
Jared became the main inspirations
behind Cup heads visual style everything
in the game is done classically for the
most part
so everything's hand drawn on paper it's
hand inked on paper all the backgrounds
are watercolor paintings in some places
they're actual physical models and all
the music of course is like live
recorded big-band tunes so from the
get-go we wanted to make sure that was
our mission to make sure we could create
this game but try to make a game as if
they were making it in the 1930s instead
of relying too heavily on digital tricks
or shortcuts so draw it it gets inked we
scan it at the computer and then the one
cheat we used is that we color it
digitally because we actually did a test
where we inked on a cell and painted on
the back with gouache scan that in put
it in the game side by side to see and
if we painted it perfectly you couldn't
really tell
difference between digital coloring and
the hand-painted so we decided to shave
five years off the development time
that's kind of basically the art process
and then once it gets handed off to the
development team there's still a major
step where the production team has to
make a chart similar to a chart they
would use in an animation feature and
they have to go through and set up all
of the animation and make sure it plays
an order it gets really complex there's
a lot of extra work that goes in even
after all of the arts complete we had to
like create our own formulas for how we
were gonna do you know using
anticipation from animation how we're
going to use that within video games but
they cross pretty seamlessly a lot of
places and like the old style of
animation had a lot of looping and other
tricks they used which ports beautifully
to video games but despite the
outstanding animation and authentic look
of the game the games difficulty became
the main focus among fans and
journalists alike but while designing
cuphead Chad and Jared weren't thinking
about making concessions based on how
hard the game became in fact they hardly
had that on their minds at all sometimes
like anything when you're doing
something creative like when he's
drawing a character or when he was doing
copy he did thousands and thousands of
versions of it and some of them are just
so bad you have to just kind of look at
it the smile and toss it away like that
you had you had some grander ideas that
we could never even pull off yeah there
was this one that would tie into the
music which was a lot more complicated
because it would be it'd be like you're
fighting on stanzas and that the actual
song playing is like the bullets and the
enemies coming out but it would have to
work so that it's not the same thing
every time otherwise it's just a
memorizing pattern so like when we
talked about the logistics of it it
would have to have so many different
variants of the song well making sure
that the song is actually playable and
syncs up to everything yeah you could
have set something up and then just
randomly had things come out but to like
keep adjusting and it would have taken
us a long period of time it'd be really
cool but it would probably have taken us
three or three full bosses worth of time
we were just like maybe not typically if
you see a cartoon themed game it's may
be aimed like you know younger children
or yeah exactly
you're gonna sit around play this on a
Saturday morning but we didn't set out
to do that it's almost like a side
effect that the art style actually has
drawn other people who would never play
this type of game towards it and really
liked it and at the same time people who
think they're gonna come play just an
easy kind of you know small neat
experience but I think that's like the
best part is like to enjoy certain sex
that difficulty is just a natural thing
like everybody feels the satisfaction
from winning but some people need the
challenge a little bit steeper to get it
I do always personally feel - if it's
just that one step harder when it's
finally done like you find yourself like
cheering or actually animating and being
like it's over never again
like so that's that's part of like the
design to me was that's what I believe
some of the old games had so to bring
that to a new generation to give them
that feeling of overcoming something
challenging and I personally don't think
cup heads that far off it's not old
school in any which way like if you said
you start with three men and three
continues and you have to beat the game
I would have been like it's a little
8-bit well even even the original Super
Mario Brothers is not an easy game if
you if you help played retro games
before it's oh my god no I can't imagine
anybody beating Mario one look if you
handed that over to them and they'd see
the game over screen probably on the
first level if they hadn't played a
platformer and they just like this is
the cheapest meanest game alive whereas
I'm really glad that the aesthetic is so
strong for us that it actually made
people be like what I want to see what
comes next and what I find is most
people are better I think a willingness
is a different thing than like a
difficulty like I would say Battletoads
is past the point of difficult because
it's not reactionary and it's an entire
memorization to have a chance to say
like I did it but I think at the same
time difficult games aren't for everyone
no you weren't yeah honing in on it make
sure we make a challenging game we just
wanted to make something authentic for
that era and then running guns just felt
like it was one of those like
underrepresented genres like there are
there are good games within it but like
outside of contra and Metal Slug and
just our heroes how many others can you
name within that us like I'd like to up
that genre and have more credentials for
it to be like there are fantastic games
there are gun star heroes and somehow
get our name cup head tossed in it's
definitely not something we set out to
make but it's incredible now like even
be named like hey contra is a cool game
but cup heads also up there with Contras
just yeah it seems still surreal in my
brain yeah I can't really I can't attach
myself to what that is I'm almost
elected to slight one step away what
before like cuphead is one of the better
running guns and you're like I'll tell
my grandkids or something like that's
the time when it'll snap and then I can
be like come look at this jerk
that's a runs and guns and they'll be so
proud of grandpa cianjur might have a
grand tale to tell their descendants but
they aren't the only people on the team
that share the moldenhauer name there's
a very strong sense of family within the
studio and that's not hyperbole a good
chunk of studio mvhr is comprised of the
moldenhauer relatives as well as close
friends Wow we have some myself I'm the
art director my wife is a producer and
inker on the game and of course we have
jared is the lead designer ryan
moldenhauer is our cousin and he's like
kind of master of everything who is it
for the largest portion of the end of
the project he was running all the
production art pattern world of ours or
other cousin which is he was doing all
the coloring in the game and like a few
other you know wearing a few other hats
it's it's yeah it's really really cool
that like we have family members working
on a project and we all get along super
well it also isn't like randomly pulling
from any family member to like build a
family team it was also the people who
we played games with Chad I Ryan Tyler
the amount of times we spent on couch in
the basement playing things and talking
about ideas it's like a perfect mix
because you don't have as much confusion
between let's say two people who know a
lot about something at least need to
like learn to understand how each other
communicates or what they kind of their
pros and cons are but since we all know
each other and have like shared so much
time growing up together it's just far
easier and it doesn't really feel like
you're working together yeah just kind
of like these feels like the old days we
were just talking around brainstorming
ideas Chris Madigan the musician like he
grew up five or six blocks down so we
played games together our whole life he
went on to be a jazz master yeah
classically trained percussion trained
it was just an easy mix because we knew
we've won a jazz soundtrack we need
somebody who we know we can trust who
also understands what video games sound
like so we gave him the reins it was
baby steps for him to because originally
the game was gonna be eight bosses yeah
we said we just need eight tracks and he
said that's manageable but it kind of
ballooned into over 50 tracks some
people even haven't noticed there's
multiple mixes with different solos on
all the tracks so even when you play
boss again you'll hear different solos
and the song is slightly different but
when we approach Chris and said we
wanted like these you know short video
game tunes the jazz side of him really
wanted to finish the song so as long as
the song sounds like it fits in the game
will kind of let Chris have his leeway
but it it led to a much better
soundtrack in the end even if you don't
hear it the whole song through a play
it's almost like its own experience to
listen to the music after and if you're
gonna go that crazy to like with the
animation and being like everything is
gonna be a watercolor background look
carved structures at a styrofoam and
paint it and then set up rigs to get
like a full set of photos to create a 3d
object that it also wasn't that much of
a stretch when he's like well what if I
finished these songs what if I made them
longer than needed obviously once we got
into it it just it kind of took over
like make sure this is like perfectly
done the old way let's pile on more work
so it's more authentic and it just it
kind of almost almost spun out of
control clearly though things worked out
beautifully for them the only thing that
seemed to spin out of control was the
popularity of the game with cuphead
selling more than a million digital
copies in the first month of release but
now that the brothers have made their
dream game what could possibly be next
for the team
I think the key thing is just we get to
keep making games and that's kind of
what we got that was our dream goal
going into this whole thing and now we
get to continue making games and we just
have to take some real time like hey you
know we need some time to act like yeah
make a plan set back I know the
appropriate thing that a company does is
you're working on a second game before
you're done launching but we were 100%
focused it's not like we had meetings
and sat down and discussed what the next
games gonna be and how we're gonna work
with it so we got a lot a lot to know
like think your bum up and do we were
like what did I avoid for the last year
and then you're like oh yeah yard work
doesn't do itself it still feels really
busy it's just I finally can do a break
of different things but it's really
exciting to have a fan base now an
audience who appreciates leg dot space
2d and yeah that's the one thing that
was also like a slight goal was to be
like a company again that employs people
in 2d art classical 2d animation yeah I
think that's gonna be as long as we can
run it that's one of our main goals no
matter which way you approach it it's
still more expensive to go the classical
animation especially if you do
everything on shore so it's a
double-edged sword like is the company
I'm gonna take a risk when they know
that there's digital methods that can
speed up the process and save a ton of
money it's it's hard yeah I just know
enough about the industry I can't speak
to it on that sense to be like I'm
projecting a 5% increase this year on 2d
and I'm hoping to see 25 by 2020 but if
that happened that would be like the
most rewarding thing about making the
game was if anything was inspired to be
like produce another 2d cartoon or other
studios to open up to make games with
animation I would be very happy if we
could somehow claim that that was us but
I don't know we'll see if nothing else
the game has inspired people from around
the world to share their love for the
characters and for old cartoons
themselves handcrafted art tends to have
a certain level of intimacy involved
with it and whether it's a painting a
sculpture or a little cartoon man with a
cup for a head you can feel the humanity
behind it behind the brushstrokes or the
fingerprints embedded into the clay or
in cup heads case the scratchy ink work
that outlines the characters and we see
that same intimacy within Studio mvhr
themselves a close-knit group of people
simply want you to make a game that they
themselves would love we may never see
another game that looks quite like
cuphead but that's okay as long as
people see it and use as inspiration for
their own improbable pursuits besides
what's another 80 years wait
[Music]